gosh that totally makes sense because
it's like when you're like yeah women
are terrible nowadays they're like not
all women like um I know a lot of people
that are not religious don't believe in
the Bible and they don't believe in the
story of Adam and Eve but there's a
reason why these stories exist think
about it eve eat the apple and only God
knows for how long she had knowledge I
was watching Adam running around naked
just think about the implication of that
only God knows how long he had that
knowledge that she could see obviously
that she was naked and then because the
Bible says here she ate the upper and
she gave it to Adam but it doesn't tell
us how long how long yeah
she probably gave it to him when she got
bored and was like okay yeah I've seen
it all you know let me just relieve him
of his of his stupidity and it also
shows like the visceral reaction we get
from Red Pill content where they say
you're just hating on women you're just
Eve I'm just a massage and just a big
misogynist